talking about the internal issues of the
european level commissioner i'd like to
sit there just for a moment
is this european bureaucracy over the
years eu lawmakers have come in for
criticism for what's being called
bonkers brussels bureaucracy the dead
hand of bureaucracy
is destroying innovation and destroying
jobs in europe
people seem to like calling the eu a
bureaucracy
an excessively complicated thing that
can be hardly understood
and they're not entirely wrong the eu
isn't easy to understand
however this characterization hides a
better description
the eu not as a bureaucracy but as a
technocracy
a system of government where decision
makers are appointed on the basis of
their expertise
and ability although technocracies
are obviously preferable to
bureaucracies technocracies
can still have problems in the
commission
policy is produced through multiple
policy departments known as directorate
generals
and in these departments there are
hundreds of staff members
working for the eu that weren't directly
elected but play a role in producing
policy
it's easy to look at the hundreds of
unelected eu staff members
with different roles in different
departments and cry bureaucracy
but this is actually more of an example
of a technocracy
because becoming one of these staff
members is not easy
in order to get into the eu and become
part of the staff you have to take a
test conducted by
epso the european personnel selection
office
the test that applicants have to take
has an average success rate of 2 percent
which is lower than harvard's acceptance
rate and although the process of
becoming an official
can change depending on the type of job
an applicant wants in the eu
alongside a hard and selective test to
begin with it's very likely that the
candidate will have to go through
multiple layers of process
to really put this in perspective
between 2012 and 2018
411 000 candidates competed for 7 000
positions
on the epso reserve list people that
strongly believe in the value of
meritocracy
may think that this is good a difficult
process to filter out the most
successful candidates
but the episode process is far from
perfect and has a couple of issues
for one the eu has struggled with
recruiting officials and has had to
change its recruitment process because
of a lack of supply
secondly the distribution of staff in
the commission is not necessarily
representative of europe
the eu is highly biased towards belgian
nationality and lacks representation
relative to population for countries
like germany france
and also the uk before it left the eu
and this may be a necessary trade-off
it's not a given that experience will be
spread equally across countries
and if institutions prioritize national
representation they may lose something
in regards to specialized knowledge
however a selection procedure based on
filtering out the best candidates
can also feed into the perception of a
euro bubble
it should not be a shock that eu
institutions are skewed
towards well-educated cosmopolitans who
do have a relatively similar
global view of what the eu should become
and the average eu citizen
does not live like the average applicant
for the eu commission
who usually have multiple degrees from
prestigious universities
politico has reported that many people
that arrive in brussels
attempt to get ahead in the eu which is
obvious provided the already difficult
steps it takes
to get there but this may also result in
candidates having to give into the euro
bubble
which can make it more difficult for
different but important views on
proactive eu reform
to see the light